as we speak and it may already have
happened by the time you listen to
today's show
the house of representatives is debating
in advance of voting and they may have
already voted by the time you listen to
this
about the second impeachment of donald
trump now you all know if you watch the
monday show
and or the tuesday show that i believe
impeachment
should not be a political calculation
but rather a responsibility
a duty that the house of representatives
has
question one float very simple flowchart
did the president do something worthy of
impeachment
if the answer is yes then you impeach
there are no other considerations
because it is
such an important responsibility placed
on congress
what is very interesting is that this
will not be
merely a partisan impeachment in the
house
we are hearing from more and more
republicans that they are
indeed going to vote to impeach they may
already have
depends on when you listen to this
congressman john
catko from new york was the first
republican to say
publicly he will vote to impeach donald
trump
over his role in inciting a violent mob
to storm the capital last week
he said he will join democrats today
when they vote to impeach trump for
willfully inciting violence
against the government of the united
states we then heard from liz
cheney from wyoming republican
congresswoman and daughter of former
republican vice president dick cheney
she will vote
to impeach today then we heard from
republican congressman
adam kinzinger that he will vote to
impeach
saying uh that um it can what trump did
essentially cannot be ignored period and
uh this is starting to get very very
interesting we also heard from
republican congressman fred upton
that he will vote to impeach donald
trump
and that puts the number of republicans
that will be voting to impeach trump
at more than zero and that's what
matters now ultimately we will get
uh the full number we i i don't yet know
what it is as of this moment the vote
is likely happening or minutes from
taking place
uh but ultimately the real questions
are going to be in the senate and we are
going to talk about that
in a little bit i don't i don't want to
get ahead of myself but there's going to
be a real question as to whether
any republicans would be willing to vote
to convict in the senate and we will get
to that
now um how much praise do these
republicans deserve
in the house for voting to impeach very
little
that's that's the reality the dominoes
are falling and that's good
republicans are starting to jump ship
many of them many are not but many are
um and to me this mostly is
opportunistic uh uh individuals
trying to save themselves that being
said i
still say keep them coming i still think
again
people should just vote based on what
happened what happened is donald trump
behaved in an impeachable manner
and thus any vote to impeach is the
correct vote and that should be welcomed
but it's a lot easier to be the second
person to take a stand and second
applies in a number of ways here
this is the second impeachment of donald
trump we have already seen
some republicans like mitt romney and
others
distance from donald trump and it's
always easier
when your participation is going to get
less and less attention and the the
second person to jump on board gets less
attention than the first
and the tenth gets less attention than
the second and that's the way
it goes and ultimately many of these
republicans are realizing there's simply
nothing to gain
and everything to lose from continuing
to side with a
seditious president i hate to be so
cynical about this
but this is republicans doing exactly
what we predicted they're just doing it
like a week sooner than we expected and
what i mean by that is
there was every indication for over a
year
certainly for months and you've heard me
talk about it every indication
that once trump is gone the republican
party both those who supported trump and
those
who supported him publicly but not
privately
and those who started to distance from
trump publicly at a relatively earlier
stage
this was always the plan the plan was
always when trump is gone
to do a sort of on steroids version of
what they did with george w bush
remember george w bush did not campaign
with john mccain in 2008
george w bush was unpopular uh and
republicans made the calculation
it probably hurts john mccain to have
george w bush on the campaign trail
this is like a steroids version of that
where you are going to see
tons of republicans uh going to
pretending trump
i barely even remember that and i
certainly wasn't with it and
and going back to all of the things the
republican party has pretended to care
about
for a very long time we've got to reduce
the debt and the deficit
religious freedom lower taxes cut
business regulation
get in the way of so-called government
takeovers
by democrats and sometimes maybe they'll
call them communists and socialists etc
etc
um so this is not a surprise at all
it's simply happening a week to two
weeks
before trump leaves office we were more
leaning in the direction that it would
happen once trump is actually gone
that's it and they deserve no praise
they don't deserve to have
their reputations rehabilitated but to
the extent
that it's correct for them to vote to
impeach
i'm with it and after the break we are
going to talk about what's happening in
the senate
including multiple reports that mitch
mcconnell
is pleased with donald trump being
impeached a second time but what does
that mean
when mitch mcconnell says it the devil
is certainly in the details so we'll
have more after the break
and also on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is
helix sleep i sleep on a helix mattress
at home
i absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them about sponsoring the
david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you first
hand every helix mattress comes with a
10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video